imaginez un monde où vous ne seriez pas
le maître du temps un monde où vous
seriez bloqué chez vous et où pour
sortir il faudrait montrer patte blanche
un monde où chaque projet serait
conjuguer au conditionnel et dépendrait
d'une autre personne que vous un monde
où se projeter dans l'avenir
croire en des jours meilleurs serait
complètement utopique
un monde où par peur par prévention vous
demande de rester un peu à l'écart des
autres au moins pour une période
un monde où les gens penseraient savoir
ce qui est bon pour vous sans jamais
vous demander votre avis
je sais ce monde est un peu difficile à
imaginer quoique je sais pas si ça vous
parle petit indice ça n'a rien à voir et
que la pandémie est non ce monde fictif
qui n'en est pas un c'est celui des
personnes avec une maladie psychique
troubles bipolaires schizophrénie
troubles anxieux trop des conduites
alimentaires a derrière toutes ces
maladies il ya des personnes qui ne
disparaissent pas derrière des symptômes
ou des termes compliqués des personnes
qui comme vous et moi aspire à vivre de
tous les façons possibles
des personnes qui ont envie de se
rétablir de cette maladie et c'est vrai
qu'il est joli ce terme rétablissement
encore faut-il bien l'utiliser et
changer de regard dessus
parce qu'au quotidien on parle de
rétablissement souvent médicale vous
savez ce médecin qui vous dis je vous
trouve mieux je vous sens rétabli moi
j'ai l'impression que les choses se
passent mieux pour vous donc comme danse
comme si d'un seul coup l'expert de
votre maladie l'expert de qui vous êtes
ce serait le médecin que vous avez en
face de vous ou votre entourage
l'idée du rétablissement c'est de
changer de regard de parcé d'art
établissement médical un rétablissement
personnel remettre la personne au centre
qu'elle se sente experte en fait de ce
qu'elle est et pas non pas qu'elle se
sente c'est évidemment ce qu'elle est de
se dire de passer de je vous trouve
mieux ah oui je me sens mieux avec ma
définition à moi du rétablissement avec
la définition que je m'étais donné mais
ce qui est intéressant de s'intéresser
au rétablissement personnel et de faire
ce changement de paradigme c'est
qu'avant tout il faut vraiment
s'intéresser à la personne
qui a derrière le patient ou d'usagé eux
tout simplement mais en fait qui es-tu
qui est une fois en face de moi au
quotidien quand vous rencontrez
quelqu'un votre cerveau c'est assez
facile il vous regarde ils voient qu'ils
vous êtes vos envies vos caractères
caractère vos qualités et vos défauts et
si vous étiez si vous aviez quelque
chose une petite une petite maladie quoi
que ce soit ça passe derrière c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on regarde le problème
en psychiatrie c'est qu'on a des supers
lunettes des choses des lunettes
vraiment comment vous dire aux
technologies avec deux verres
hyperpuissante celui de la psychiatrie
est celui de la stigmatisation la
psychiatrie c'est très simple on vous
habille un diagnostic vous êtes partez
vous êtes parti pour et d'un seul coup
vous disparaissez derrière ce diagnostic
vous n'êtes que ce diagnostic pour ça
qu'on vous dit vous êtes un schizo vous
êtes un bi polaire alors que la fente
vaudrait vous êtes atteint de
schizophrénie et damman ça voudrait ça
vous donnerai pas l'idée viendrait pas à
l'idée d'aller vous dire tiens
aujourd'hui je vais voir des cancéreux
c'est pas trés socialement acceptée en
psychiatrie ça passe je vends un schizo
ça ne choque personne et puis en plus
affublé de ce costume de passion de
maladie vous avez le terme la
stigmatisation schizophrénie ou la la la
double personnalité et ces personnes qui
tuent des gens j'espère qu'il n'a pas
dans la salle sinon je serais en danger
puisqu'on est dans le noir on voit rien
et d'un seul coup eh ben ce cerveau avec
avec nous ses lunettes psychiatrie
stigmatisation et ben ils ne voient que
cette ombre que ce diagnostic et l'usagé
le patient d'un seul coup il disparaît
comme si tout ce qui lui arrivait
c'était dû à la maladie quand il va bien
qu'il est content c'est grâce au
traitement quand il va mal ou qui donne
son avis ou qu'il ait pas d'accord à
quelque chose où là c'est la maladie qui
revient là ces symptômes tu devrais
reprendre ce traitement
en soit l'idée du rétablissement avant
tout et la graine du rétablissement
c'est l'identité et ne jamais oublier
qu'il ya une personne derrière un
diagnostic est derrière un patient sans
ça vous prendrez toujours les mauvaises
décisions et quand je dis vous on le
verra mais faire cet effort là cognitifs
d'enlever les lunettes de soleil à notre
cerveau c'est valable pour nous tous au
quotidien
l'autre héros du rétablissement à c'est
évidemment l'espoir l'espoir que il y
aura un après l'histoire que ça ira
mieux j'espère qu'on va pouvoir se
reconstruire malgré la maladie et avec
la maladie ce terreau de l'espoir
évidemment qu'il faut que la personne
puisse la voir mais il faut que les gens
autour d'elle puisse la voir aussi si
vous pensez quelqu'un qui est déprimé ne
se remettra jamais ou ne fera que
rechuté si vous quelqu'un que si vous
pensez quelqu'un qui a perdu une jambe
ne pourra plus faire de sport si vous
pensez que quelqu'un avec une
schizophrénie est bon à enfermer ne
pourra jamais vivre seul que vous soyez
un aidant que vous savez un soignant
comment voulez vous que cette personne
est l'espoir alors que dans les yeux des
autres qu'elles regardent il n'y a aucun
espoir sans espoir il n'y a pas de pas
de projet et pas de rétablissement est
clairement l'espoir c'est le terreau du
rétablissement l'identité l'espoir c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment avoir
en tête au quotidien et c'est pas
d'avoir un espoir aveugle s'est défait
en fait que quand on laisse les
personnes se reconstruire notamment en
tant que patient mais aussi en tant que
personne d'endosser la cap d'une maladie
psychique mais de se reconstruire avec
et ben l'espoir est permis et tous les
projets quels qu'ils soient sont
vraiment importants mais il faut faire
attention parce qu'au quotidien on peut
se vouloir empathique avec les personnes
atteintes d'une maladie psychique et se
dire ouh là là mais il est vulnérable il
est tragique je sens qu'il va pas bien
on va le protéger à mettre sous bulle
le problème c'est quand on met on veut
protéger de la maladie c'est pas
protégés de la vie c'est pas empêcher
quelqu'un d'aller re tenter des choses
de se redonner des des objectifs de se
redonner des challenge protéger de la
vie ça n'a jamais protégé de la maladie
c'est pour ça qu'il faut éviter de
mettre les gens sous cloche si on garde
les gens sous cloche on garde l'espoir
les sports sous cloche et dans ce cas là
pas de rétablissement possible et c'est
hyper important dans un premier temps
pour le développement la personne mais
mieux que ça en fait laissé la place à
l'espoir c'est créer l'environnement
propice à une demande l'aide si vous
laissez quelqu'un de déprimer tout seul
chez lui sans espoir de reconstruction
sans nouveaux projets il vous demandera
pas des dents fait si vous lui dites que
c'est pas possible repose toi
pourquoi demander de l'aide pour pouvoir
passer de la cuisine à la chambre de la
chambre à la salle de bain alors que
quand on laisse par projet c'est pas
mettre la personne en difficulté s'est
créé un environnement propice à ce que
la personne se sente revivre refasse des
choses se redonne des objectifs et si
elle en difficulté s'il ya des obstacles
entre elle et ses objectifs eh ben elle
demandera de l'aide tout simplement ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas donc
clairement ne gardons pas l'espoir des
gens sous cloche même quand on est
inquiet pour eux même si on pense qu'ils
vont se casser la gueule de toute façon
vous n'êtes pas des madame irma et nous
sommes pas des mains dernièrement on
peut pas savoir ce qui va se passer donc
laissons la chance aux personnes qui ont
envie de se tester c'est vraiment
important
pourquoi ça pourtant aussi de ne pas
garder l'espoir sous cloche mais
peut-être que vous l'avez déjà vécu mais
amener quelqu'un à se faire aider
notamment en psychiatrie c'est pas hyper
évident
vous savez il ya ce truc non mais moi
j'ai pas besoin d'un psychiatre moi je
suis forme j'ai du caractère dans la
famille ça ne fait pas de toute façon
jamais à se faire aider quand on est une
maladie psychique c'est pas évident
pourquoi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
stigmatisation l'a dit et puis c'est pas
palpable d'une maladie psychique c'est
compliqué hein c'est on n'arrive pas à
regarder il ya un bout là il ya un bout
là il ya un trait au milieu bon a priori
cpt il n'y a pas de débat la dépression
nous la schizophrénie les troubles
bipolaires on s'est pas montré là c'est
là dans le cerveau c'est là ce que c'est
là que ça va pas
c'est de là qu'on va réparer ça ça
n'existe pas donc amenés à se faire
aider c'est pas évident parce qu'elle
est amenée à se faire aider au service
de quoi donc ce qu'on peut faire
généralement pour aider les gens il ya
la porte d'entrée des soins en fait
clairement la porte d'entrée des soins
tiens vous allez mal je vous propose sa
ou à cause de votre maladie vous
entendez des voix je peux vous proposer
quelque chose où vous avez des problèmes
d'habiter sociale nous pouvons
travailler ça mais travailler un
symptôme est allé aux soins au service
d'un symptôme ou d'une maladie c'est pas
forcément ce patrick thifault en fait
allé se soigner pour se faire soigner
c'est patrick qui font ça dépasse pas le
leur où leurs ennemis du soin une
hauteur par contre qui quand même plus
plus abordable qui donne plus d'espoir
on l'a dit pas si la porte d'entrée des
projets je vais pas me soigner pour
guérir de ma dépression je me soigner
parce que je me suis donné comme ça que
ça comme objectif j'ai envie de retrait
retravaillé j'ai envie de gravir
l'everest j'ai envie de faire tout un
tas de trucs dans la vie mais cette
dépression c'est un obstacle cette
maladie c'est un obstacle et cet
obstacle je veux lever et d'un seul coup
le soin qu'on propose ils rendent plus
par la porte d'entrée des soins non pas
jusqu au service de la maladie c'est
vraiment au service d'un projet
je vous propose ça parce que vous m'avez
dit que vous vouliez faire ça et je vous
propose vos propres ça pas uniquement
parce que vous êtes malade et ça change
tout en fait notamment peut-être que
certains d'entre vous le savent mais il
ya certaines maladies psychiques
notamment la schizophrénie ou un des
symptômes c'est de penser qu'on n'est
pas malade tout ce qui nous arrive n'est
pas une maladie dont clairement accepté
un soin pour une maladie qu'on pense ne
pas avoir ça serait franchement bizarre
par contre quand on a une schizophrénie
on est une personne comme tous les
autres on a des projets et accepter
quelque chose qui lève les obstacles
entre nous et notre projet ça ça a du
sens donc clairement d'un seul coup on
voit comment les projets ils deviennent
ils ouvrent la porte aux soins en fait
et ça c'est hyper important la manière
dont on amène les choses est clairement
faire de la psychiatrie différemment
aujourd'hui c'est ça s'est intéressé à
la personne à son rétablissement
personnel et non pas que son
rétablissement médical
clairement vous êtes on nous a dit
140-150 dans la salle vous faites tous
probablement des métiers différents
vous avez tous la possibilité au
quotidien d'ouvrir la porte des projets
à une personne
que vous soyez moniteur d'auto-école
médecin patrons d'entreprises tout ce
que vous voulez un jour vous serez
confronté à une personne avec une
maladie psychique au début vous aurez
peur vous demanderez ce qui se passe
demanderez si elle est capable si elle
peut travailler dans votre entreprise si
ça vaut le coup
clairement posez vous la question que si
vous lui fermer la porte de ces projets
de son espoir voulu fermer aussi la
porte des soins donc quand vous
quitterez cette pièce vous saurez que à
100% sûr vous serez confronté un jour à
ouvrir une porte tout ce que je demande
c'est surtout pas de la fermer au
maximum de l'ouvrir merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]